foreign
[Music]
I said no to you when you first asked me
out do you want to go to dinner with me
and
the bat no no no no is because I'm
moving to Brazil
[Music]
like there a lagoon
they told me not to go but
I didn't listen
she told me I had three wishes
when it falls off my wrist
those three wishes will come true
do not cut it
[Laughter]
Emma
with me
all three of your wishes will come true
don't know why
would you even know there's no sun up in
the sky
if you crossed into a fairy tale
Storm is Coming
swirled
that we may never know we've trespassed
through I
am
gloom and misery everywhere
[Music]
I need to know where my wife is
people don't just disappear
hello which
You Don't See
but you will
[Music]
foreign